we're in Paris the Eiffel Towers behind
us it is as beautiful as both of you
it's still gorgeous to be here with you
right now in Paris are you excited to be
back very exciting you have a few
nicknames you have King stache and
hammer Man of Steel and hers is a doctor
of Fine Arts first of all you look
different without the mustache but
you're a beautiful skin you look great
you really do but now you've been in
this film where you said you'd love to
do the stunts that you were looking
forward to it
did Tom Cruise give you a pep talk
before you started and that's something
you kept with you throughout the film I
don't think there was a pep talk I said
when Tom and I came together on this
movie we hadn't met before it was I was
just expressing my excitement of doing
all the stunts and he went really and I
said yeah I've know I really do and you
went okay he's like clearly believing
that I wasn't gonna do it but then
throughout the movie he realized that I
actually wanted to get stuck in and and
he was just so excited that there was
someone else who was like him he's
willing to do really crazy stuff you see
we didn't say anything to that you kind
of said okay I'll keep this in mind
because he's sick I mean as far as as
far as advice goes and just pearls of
wisdom there are too many to count like
I had him and McHugh on set titans of
the industry and I just sit there and
listen and ask questions all day really
okay cool
taking that with me thank you very much
and there's that epic scene where you
have a fight scene I want to ruin for
everybody with Tom Cruise with Ethan
Hunt did you have any hesitation hitting
Tom Cruise yeah was that a great moment
for you uh it was the whole movie has
been a series of great moments it's been
incredibly exciting yeah now when you
watch it film like this you think about
your own fear
because you go through all of these
different stunts and I sitting there
what am I scared of do you guys have any
fears
hmm usually mine you know that
reoccurring dream that I have you know
maybe we all have you know have one mine
tends to be forgetting my lines you know
and usually going onstage but anywhere
forgetting my lines not being prepared
and I'm going on in about 10 minutes and
I keep trying to cram cram cram and
people keep you know pulling you asking
you to do this rushing so I can never
concentrate and then I wake up and I'm
relieved that's beautiful yes yes I have
that same dream the light before big
scenes yeah then I wake up and it
becomes a reality mm-hmm how do you prep
the night before you know it stunts
coming the next day do you do you sleep
are you just anxious um well the stunts
we rehearse them obviously an awful lot
and so when it comes to actually doing
the stunts that day it's just the stunts
but on a set location so it's kind of
drilled in that the nerves are gone by
then the nerves normally kicking around
take three or four where you're thinking
oh this one's gonna hurt I can tell
that's what I'm gonna get this one wrong
if you don't get your piece of the stunt
exactly right you can end up injuring
your partner very badly all yourself
that's not fun it's sometimes it is yeah
as long as you get it right yeah yeah
you are the queen and black panther you
were amazing in that film and you are
the boss as the CIA in this filthy you
own a girl it's all you in this film
when you have these type of roles do you
think it's empowering women is changing
now and that there are some great roles
for women now that certainly is the the
feeling the spirit in the air right now
and they've come on the heels of each
other and that has been the dialogue in
the conversation than it has been a you
know a source of strength and
representation to see ourselves up there
on the screen
in all our you know complicated
fascinating ways 20 years since how
Stella got her groove what happy
anniversary yeah thank you
that you don't spoke to so many women do
you have fond memories of it absolutely
yeah in Jamaica yeah that's as beautiful
as being here you know I have a question
for you because Whitney's new movie just
came out and you do Waiting to Exhale
your directorial debut and now there's a
new one that's coming out what its gonna
say what do you think about her spirit
still being alive and oh my gosh you
know we we all know how brilliant how
absolutely the god-given talent that she
possessed and and it's just it's just
always will always continue to be so sad
that she's no longer with us but we
still have our voice we still have our
voice that we can listen to and enjoy
and that beautiful smile that beautiful
spirit that she possessed you just
concentrate on that that's the best so
I'll just keep it right there I love
that
now man is steel right here if you'd had
a brother
would you consider Tom Cruise to be
Superman's brother
Oh Superman had a brother alright boys
yeah funny girls oh we've just had our
first girl in the series of nephews and
now nice so would you consider him
getting into the spandex and being part
of your team as Superman is that
possible I don't know if it's possible
I bet but I think it'd be cool yeah yeah
and if if possible if Superman were to
go against the real-life Ethan Hunt who
would win Oh Superman I mean really
amazing he's amazing but he's not
Superman
tends to fold the style roughly fly I
like that how will you describe the
journey fans will go through watching
Mission Impossible mi6
well held on to my sleeve you held on to
the seed I leaned forward I probably
disturbed you with the sounds I was
emitting it was a lot of animation of
the journey it's like the previous
Mission Impossible movies but everything
is that they got about a 10% better
crazier more wild but this has a certain
gravitas and weightiness to it there's a
psychological book component an
emotional component which
which really has made this a different
experience there's there's an emotional
journey which come with all the
characters of the team as well as as
those not on the team but it's just
encompassed within this amazing thrill
ride like that I was on the edge of my
seat the whole time too
and I'm sorry about England losing I
don't feel bad I don't know should we
just give you a hug next time cross
bronx thank you guys thank you very much